Are you surprised to see him
openly criticizing DeSantis this early?
What do you think
No, I'm not surprised.
If you think back on the 16 primary,
he was taking shots
at everybody in the race,
even people who were at zero and 1%
in the case of DeSantis.
There are a lot of polls
where DeSantis is ahead of Donald Trump,
including in key early states.
So I'm not surprised.
I expect him to come after
DeSantis pretty hard.
You know, Trump's the only person
officially in the race right
now, but it sure looks like the status
this is going to run.
And if you look at the whole field,
the Florida governor
looks like the one
who might have the reservoir of support
among all corners of the party
that actually beat Donald Trump
in a primary.
Well, then,
what do you make about this
phone call
we're learning about with Nikki
Haley calling him, saying she
she wants to get in the race
and failing him out.
And he said basically,
if that's what you feel in your heart,
go for it.
I mean, on one hand,
it really works to his advantage,
right, to have as many join the
race as possible.
Yeah.
A big field
who actually stays in it
through the voting helps
Donald Trump in 2016.
He only got about 45%
of the Republican vote,
but he won the nomination
because of the winner take all system.
You would just have to get the most votes
in these states to get all the delegates.
And so if he could get a big field
that stays in it for far too long
it would really advantage him
or frankly,
anyone who kind of carries a strong base.
But it's not a majority of the party.
My anticipation is
the field will be smaller
this time around.
And people will
drop out earlier than they did last time.
What you really need,
if you want to take out
Donald Trump,
is to get it down
to a one on one match with somebody
that people really like.
And right now
it looks like the Sanders
is that first
and other people will give it a go.
But certainly DeSantis
is in a
is in a class
by himself of the non-Trump candidates.
Yeah.
And on that note,
I mean, we've been seeing
some interesting polling data
out of those key early primary states.
Ron DeSantis coming in
well ahead of Trump
among Republicans in New Hampshire,
leading the former president by a full
12 points.
There are similar numbers there in South
Carolina is
I mean, with numbers
like that,
Scott, is Trump
losing his title as the party's
2024 frontrunner?
I think he is still
probably the frontrunner
if you take all the metrics
into account money organization
you know
a cadre of people
who are fully dependent upon him
for their livelihoods.
I mean he still is a quite
a formidable candidate.
So I guess nominally
he's the frontrunner.
And plus there are no other candidates
technically at the moment.
But you can't look at this polling
if you're on this
and not be fully intrigued
by where you stand.
You've done nothing.
You've not filed a committee.
All you've done is run for reelection.
And Trout, your Democrat opponent.
And yet you are
right here in the driver's
seat of the candidates
who want to take on
and maybe take out Donald Trump.
So I expect him to run,
and I think he's going to
be quite popular.
I've seen a lot of polling, Pamela,
from around the country
in different states, private polling.
I've got to tell you,
Trump still popular.
The Santas is just as popular,
but he doesn't have nearly the amount
of detractors inside the party
that Trump does.
Yeah.
I mean, even just anecdotally
in our home state of Kentucky,
when I was talking to folks
there, recently,
there was a
theme of folks
who used to support Trump saying,
I'd like to see Ron DeSantis
get in this race.
I'd like to see him run.
But, you know, at the same time,
you've got to look at the reality here.
Right,
and what Trump did the last time
and what he is capable of doing again.
Matthew Continetti,
has an interesting piece
in The Free Beacon where he warns
that the US political class
is behaving
alarmingly similar
to how they did in the run up
to 2016
writing once again
Trump's opponents
think he will just disappear.
No Republican
wants to attack him directly,
but the only way to thwart him,
Trump is to make voters choose
someone else.
I mean, at what point do his challengers
start challenging him?
Even Ron DeSantis has been,
you know,
hasn't really been doing
that, doing
the kind of direct engagement
you might expect.
I would say pretty soon
you're going to see
people start to take further steps.
I mean, for the people who are not
Trump org is Santas.
One of the problems
they have is figuring out,
is there any oxygen for me?
I mean,
Trump and DeSantis
take up nearly the entire
oxygen in the primary right now.
Everybody else is in the low
single digits.
Even former
Vice President Pence, who's
well known,
is a single digit candidate right now.
So I'm not sure it's as much Trump
keeping them out
as it is the Santas
because of how popular
nationally with the Republicans.
But I agree with Matthew.
At some point,
somebody is going to have to take him on
and somebody is going to have to make
Republicans choose.
And I will say,
I think
broadly across the American electorate,
in both parties,
there is a demand for new candidates,
new blood, new generation of leadership.
And the party that chooses new
is going to have a huge advantage
if the other party chooses.
Oh, and if I were Ron DeSantis
and that's something I'd be making
the case for, Democrats are going, Biden,
let's pick
somebody new and ride this thing
and win it and put together a coalition
that can carry the national popular vote.
All right.
Scott Jennings, nice to see you.
Thank you.